si alguna vez han hecho pasar corriente
a través de una resistencia quizás se
hayan dado cuenta de que se pone
caliente de hecho si hacen pasar mucha
corriente la resistencia se puede poner
tan caliente que los puede quemar por lo
que hay que tener cuidado lo que digo es
que cuando tenemos corriente que fluye a
través de la resistencia se va a
calentar y es lo que vamos a explicar en
este vídeo conceptualmente porque al
pasar una corriente por una resistencia
ésta se calienta y si hay alguna manera
de calcular con exactitud qué tanto se
va a calentar nuestra resistencia cuando
pase cierta corriente por ella durante
cierto tiempo hay una forma de calcular
esto y la vamos a deducir en este vídeo
pero antes vamos a explicar
conceptualmente cómo es que al pasar una
corriente a través de una resistencia
ésta se va a calentar vamos a explicarlo
con esta corriente ahora yo he dibujado
aquí cargas positivas pero en realidad
las cargas positivas no son las que se
mueven a través de un conductor pero los
físicos pretenden que esto
ya que el que las cargas positivas se
muevan a través de un cable es
equivalente a decir que tenemos cargas
negativas que se mueven en ese cable
pero en sentido contrario y si usamos
las cargas positivas aún cuando es
técnicamente incorrecto no tendremos que
trabajar con todos esos signos negativos
es más fácil de trabajar así y es
equivalente así que podemos usarlo pero
si ustedes quieren pueden aplicar esta
misma descripción pero usando cargas
negativas que van en el sentido opuesto
a como aquí explicamos que van las
positivas va a funcionar de la misma
manera solo que tienen que tener cuidado
con los signos negativos y además esto
obscurece un poco el significado
conceptual ya que esto se oculta detrás
de muchos signos negativos así que aquí
usamos estas cargas positivas pero
recuerden que realmente son cargas
negativas que van en el sentido opuesto
y como es que estas cargas que pasan a
través de esta resistencia hacen que se
caliente pues por esto nosotros sabemos
que cuando uno
corriente fluye a través de una
resistencia tendremos un voltaje a
través de esta resistencia en otras
palabras entre este punto de aquí y este
otro punto de acá hay una diferencia en
el potencial eléctrico por lo que
tenemos un voltaje a través de esta
resistencia técnicamente vamos a
llamarle delta vez ya que es una
diferencia en el potencial eléctrico en
otras palabras ve de este lado o el
potencial eléctrico en este punto va a
tener un valor diferente al potencial
eléctrico que se encuentra en este otro
punto de la resistencia porque esto nos
interesa nos interesa porque en este
lado final en donde terminan las cargas
va a tener un potencial eléctrico más
bajo que el que tenía al inicio estas
cargas positivas se van a estar moviendo
desde un potencial eléctrico más alto
hasta un potencial eléctrico más bajo se
van a estar moviendo desde una región de
alto potencial hacia una región de bajo
potencial lo que significa que van a
estar cambiando su energía potencial de
manera que estas cargas tienen una
potencial y cuando pasan de una región
de alto potencial eléctrico a una región
de bajo potencial eléctrico comienzan
con mayor energía potencial eléctrica y
terminan con menor energía potencial
eléctrica por lo que disminuye su
energía potencial eléctrica y en el caso
de que esto los confunda un poco
recuerden que la definición de potencial
eléctrico es la cantidad de energía
potencial eléctrica por carga podemos
poner un número aquí para que esto no
sea tan abstracto digamos que b 2 es de
2 jules por colom lo que significa que
por cada cool hombre de carga en este
punto de dedos tendremos 2 jules de
energía potencial eléctrica y si ve uno
está en una región de mayor potencial
eléctrico digamos tiene 6 jules por
colom quiere decir que aquí en esta
posición de uve uno por cada color de
carga vamos a tener 6 jules de energía
potencial eléctrica así que conforme
estas cargas pasan a través de la
resistencia van a decrementar su
potencial de energía
eléctrica y aquí la pregunta obvia es a
dónde va esa energía si estas cargas
disminuyen su energía potencial
eléctrica a dónde va esa energía
potencial eléctrica mi primera idea
sería que aumentan su energía cinética
ya que yo recuerdo que en la tierra si
dejamos caer una pelota iba a
decrementar su energía potencial
gravitacional nosotros sabemos que
cuando decremento su energía potencial
gravitacional conforme va cayendo va a
aumentar su energía cinética conforme
aumenta su velocidad así que la
disminución de la energía potencial
gravitacional corresponde a un aumento
en la energía cinética sobre ese objeto
y quizá es lo que está sucediendo aquí
que conforme estas cargas pierden
energía potencial eléctrica aumentan su
velocidad pero esto no sucede recuerden
que la corriente de un lado de la
resistencia tiene que ser igual a la
corriente del otro lado de esta
resistencia así que estas cargas no se
aceleran pierden
energía potencial eléctrica pero no
aumentan su velocidad y es algo poco
intuitivo ya que estamos acostumbrados a
pensar en que algo se acelera cuando
pierde energía potencial al menos en el
caso gravitacional pero estas cargas no
van a aumentar su velocidad lo que hacen
es que calientan la resistencia así que
conforme estas cargas pasan a través de
la resistencia van a golpear las
moléculas y átomos que se encuentran
aquí como estructura de este objeto
sólido ya que las resistencias están
hechas de átomos y moléculas así que
conforme estas cargas pasan a través de
esta estructura sólida aunque recuerden
que realmente son electrones que van en
el sentido contrario pero conforme pasan
las cargas que es la misma idea éstas
golpean los átomos y moléculas y las
transfieren en energía cada vez que
hacen esto y es por eso que cuando
terminan de pasar a través de la
resistencia la dejan más caliente de lo
que estaba antes lo que quiere decir que
estos átomos están vibrando un poquito
más de lo que lo hacían antes de que
pasara esta corriente
y ya que están vibrando más de lo que lo
hacían antes tienen más energía por lo
que la temperatura de la resistencia
aumenta así que estas cargas en lugar de
quedarse toda la energía para ellas
solas la distribuyen conforme pasan en
esta resistencia y la distribuyen en
forma de calor en energía térmica y
básicamente salen aquí con la misma
energía cinética con la que entraron a
la resistencia por lo que este cambio a
la energía potencial eléctrica
corresponde a un aumento en la energía
térmica de esta resistencia y es por eso
que se calienta esta resistencia cuando
pasa corriente a través de ella pero hay
alguna forma de calcular exactamente qué
tanto se va a calentar esta resistencia
y si la hay solo tenemos que usar la
definición para potencia sabemos que la
definición de potencia es el trabajo por
el tiempo y ya que el trabajo es el
cambio de energía o la transferencia de
energía podemos escribir esto como la
cantidad de energía que esta resistencia
va a ganar por tiempo lo que queremos es
una fórmula que nos diga
qué tanta energía están depositando
estas cargas en la resistencia por
tiempo pues la energía ganada por la
resistencia viene de la pérdida de
energía potencial eléctrica de estas
cargas así que estas cargas se están
perdiendo energía potencial eléctrica y
esa energía potencial eléctrica se
transforma en energía térmica de manera
que la energía térmica que está ganando
esta resistencia es igual a la cantidad
de energía potencial eléctrica que
pierden estas cargas así que puedo
reescribir esto y decir que la potencia
va a ser igual al cambio en la energía
potencial eléctrica de estas cargas por
tiempo así que la potencia va a ser
igual a como encontramos el cambio en la
energía potencial eléctrica recuerden
que el potencial se define como la
energía potencial por la carga lo que
quiere decir que la energía potencial
eléctrica es la carga multiplicada por
el potencial eléctrico si quiero
encontrar delta y vamos a decir que es
cuando emerge u 2 menos
y esta es una manera en la que podemos
encontrar los valores de uno de manera
que la uv en dos ya que es q por b
tendremos la carga en dos por de dos
menos la u en uno lado en uno es la
carga en uno pero es la misma carga
cualquiera que ésta sea la carga que
entra en esta resistencia también va a
ser la misma carga que salga de ella así
que es la carga en 1 x b en 1 este es el
cambio en la energía potencial eléctrica
puedo re escribir esto sacando q como
factor común y nos queda que la potencia
va a ser igual a este factor como un q
que multiplica a b2 b1 esto es del tau y
es lo que vamos a sustituir aquí por
delta o delta es la diferencia entre
estas q por b y todo esto lo tenemos que
dividir entre el tiempo ya que estamos
hablando de potencia cuánto es de 2 - b
1 pues es simplemente el voltaje a
través de esta resiste
del tav es de 2 menos de 1 por lo que
reescribimos esto y decimos que esto es
igual a q
x delta ve el voltaje a través de la
resistencia dividida entre el tiempo que
le llevó a la carga pasará a través de
la resistencia y ahora sucede algo
mágico tenemos que la potencia es igual
a la carga que pasa a través de la
resistencia dividida entre el tiempo que
le llevó a esta carga pasar a través de
la resistencia pero la carga por el
tiempo es la definición de corriente y
nos queda esta fórmula hermosa factor
izamos esta q entre t y nos queda q por
'the x delta b el voltaje a través de la
resistencia pero q entre t es la
corriente por lo que la potencia va a
ser igual a la corriente a través de
esta resistencia multiplicado por el
voltaje a través de esta resistencia y
esta es la fórmula para la potencia
eléctrica esto nos dice cuántos jules de
energía térmica están siendo creados
en esta resistencia por tiempo las
unidades son jules por segundo o en
otras palabras watts porque lo que esto
nos dice es la cantidad de energía
térmica generada por segundo si el valor
de la potencia fuera igual a 20 watts
significa que habrá 20 jules de energía
eléctrica generada cada segundo lo cual
es algo que es bastante útil de saber
esta fórmula es muy útil cuando queremos
conocer qué tanta cantidad de energía se
va a usar en un foco en una tostadora en
una televisión o en cualquier
dispositivo eléctrico que queramos usar
esto nos dice qué tanta energía se va a
transformar en energía térmica o luz o
sonido o cualquiera que sea la energía a
la que se va a convertir mi energía
potencial eléctrica porque vean
suponemos que esto es energía térmica
pero la llamamos
de manera que cualquiera que sea la
energía a la que se está transformando
vino de el cambio en la energía
potencial eléctrica de estas cargas y
esto siempre se va a cumplir siempre
tendremos energía potencial eléctrica
que se va a transformar
o sea calor sea luz o sonido así que
esto no sólo funciona para resistencias
funciona para casi todos los componentes
eléctricos que convierten energía
potencial eléctrica en otro tipo de
energía y podemos reescribir esto de
varias formas por ejemplo pueden
escribirla así pero hay otro par de
maneras en las que se pueden encontrar
esta fórmula limpiamos esto y ponemos
nuestra fórmula aquí esto nos da la
potencia pero nosotros sabemos por la
ley de ohm que delta b es igual a y por
r y si ambas fórmulas son correctas pues
puedo sustituir una en la otra sustituyo
deltaven por r como esta y r y la pongo
aquí en lugar de delta b por lo que otra
forma de expresar la potencia inducida
por componentes eléctricos
y por delta pero delta veces y por ere
que es y al cuadrado por r quizá esta
versión de la fórmula pueda ser más útil
si tenemos una situación en donde no
conocemos el voltaje pero si conocemos
la corriente y la resistencia y hay otra
forma puedo despejar y de esta ley de
ohm y me queda que es igual a delta b /
r y si sustituyó delta b entre r en
lugar de ahí en esta fórmula voy a tener
otra versión de la fórmula de la
potencia y ahora la potencia va a ser
igual a delta b / r por delta b que es
igual a delta b al cuadrado el voltaje
que pasa a través de la resistencia al
cuadrado entre la resistencia y esta
fórmula nos puede ser útil cuando
conocemos los voltajes y la resistencia
pero no conocemos la corriente así que
dependiendo de lo que conozcamos esto
nos puede dar la potencia usada en una
resistencia todas estas fórmulas son
equivalentes nos van a dar el mismo
valor y para decidir cuál usar pues sólo
es cuestión de ver
conviene más con base en lo que
conozcamos en ese momento dependiendo
del problema que estemos resolviendo en
resumen cuando la corriente pasa a
través de una resistencia convierte en
energía potencial eléctrica en energía
térmica y podemos calcular la cantidad
exacta de energía potencial eléctrica
que se convierte por segundo usando la
corriente por el voltaje la corriente al
cuadrado por la resistencia o el voltaje
al cuadrado entre la resistencia